en attendant la livraison d'un véhicule
adapté on se débrouille pour le
transport pour faciliter les
déplacements des douars et jérémy un
ascenseur a été ajoutée dans la maison
familiale
d'autres travaux ont permis d'élargir
les couloirs et les portes pour que deux
fauteuils roulants puisse éventuellement
circuler les frères de 9 et 11 ans
partagent le même gène défectueux celui
de la dystrophie de duchenne
c'est une maladie qui fait qu'elle n'ait
observé
m cette maladie héréditaire incurable
qui touche surtout les garçons va
progresser l'ennemi c'est donc le temps
qui file des combats prince on se rend
compte qu'on voit sont la nouvelle qu'on
voit ce probablement sourire à nos
enfants et que seuls ces mesures à
prendre dans la
depuis sept ans c'est une étape à la
fois la famille puis à la fauche et
grandes soeurs et grands-parents inclus
préfère se concentrer sur l'aspect
pratique aux pratiques du quotidien
c'est des choses qui sont très concrètes
et que c'est facile de se concentrer sur
sept implique épi prendra que ça nous
aide justement je suis en train de
trouver des solutions je suis pas juste
bas je subis la maladie
il y a des moments où les soucis se
concentre à
l'école est planifiée pour edouard le
secondaire le chu sainte-justine suis
une soixantaine de garçons atteint de la
dystrophie de duchenne
c'est la maladie musculaire qu'on
rencontre le plus fréquemment en
pédiatrie les symptômes débute
généralement vers l'âge de 2-3 ans avec
une faiblesse qui a fait d'abord les
jambes particulièrement les cuisses donc
des garçons qui en voir une difficulté à
se relever du sol à monter les escaliers
on ne peut pas encore de cure en 2021
pour la dystrophie musculaire de
duchenne
ce qui fait en sorte que les garçons qui
sont atteints se retrouve en fauteuil
roulant typiquement vers l'âge de 10-12
ce n'est pas encore le traitement
curatif que les pédiatres et quelques
300 familles québécoises attendent mais
des chercheurs de sainte-justine espère
que la résolution permettra de préserver
les muscles en attendant la découverte
de thérapies géniques ce qu'on espère
c'est qu'avec notre nouveau traitement
on va être moins capables d'améliorer la
fonction la qualité de vie des patients
et on espère que la fed est une
inflammation d'avoir un muscle en
meilleure santé ça va améliorer
l'efficacité des traitements curatifs
dans les premiers essais la résine s'est
montré plus efficace que les
glucocorticoïdes qu'on utilise depuis
les années 70 les anti inflammatoires
qui entraîne de nombreux effets
secondaires ils font de l'ostéoporose a
déjà 11 ans
qui ont ça parce qu'il allait prendre le
qatar a qu il ya beaucoup danflous
chaque fois qu'une recherche un et six
ans c'est un horizon de ex années 50 10
ans je dirais qu'on a c'est de pas trop
optimistes on a regardé large à nos
enfants qui ont du bon vin ça que d'être
autant en même temps ça donne l'espoir
pour les autres pas ce qui n'empêche pas
jérémy de rêver à ce qu'il veut faire
plus tard
rubini
acteurs
réalisateurs de films
et
écrivain
le présent et plein de vie et aussi
d'espoir certains jours ici anne louise
despatie radio canada brossard